♪ ♪
>> THESE ARE PATRIOTS, THE
PEOPLE LIKE MARIE YOVANOVITCH --
HERS AND HONORABLE PATRIOTIC
AMERICAN.
SHE REST EVERYTHING.
HAD NOTHING TO GAIN.
>> SHE’S BEEN A REAL HERO TO HER
COLLEAGUES.
>> AMBASSADOR MARIE YOVANOVITCH,
OUR HERO.
>> Laura: NEW DOCUMENT SUGGEST
THAT IMPEACHMENT DARLING MARIE
YOVANOVITCH WASN’T COMPLETE
LEONIDAS WITH CONGRESS WHEN IT
CAME TO HUNTER BIDEN AND
BURISMA.
JOINING ME NOW WITH THE
EXCLUSIVE DETAILS AS JOHN
SOLOMON, JOURNALIST AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR ALONG WITH NEW YORK
CONGRESSMAN LEE ZELDIN.
JOHN, WHILE AMBASSADOR
YOVANOVITCH, AMBASSADOR TO THE
UKRAINE, CLAIMED OTHERWISE --
SHE CLAIMED SHE KNEW MORE ABOUT
BURISMA THEN SHE LET ON.
TELL US.
>> ABSOLUTELY, BECAUSE OF HIS
QUESTIONING FOR THIS IS WHAT WE
KNOW WHERE SHE TESTIFIED
EVERYTHING SHOULD KNOW ABOUT
BURISMA AND HUNTER BRIGHTON --
FROM PRESS REPORTS.
CONGRESSMAN KEPT -- ONLY KNOW
ABOUT PRESS REPORTS, SHE SAID
YEAH, THAT’S ALL I REMEMBERED.
IT TURNS OUT SHE HAD MEETINGS
DIRECTLY WITH BURISMA
REPRESENTATIVES.
SHE RECEIVED LETTERS, DETAILED
LETTERS FROM BURISMA
REPRESENTATIVES IT DETAILING
THEIR EFFORTS TO GET OUT FROM
UNDER A CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION
BEFORE DONALD TRUMP BECAME
PRESIDENT.
SHE DIDN’T MENTION ANY OF THOSE
AND THERE’S ONLY TWO GOOD
OPTIONS HERE, RIGHT?
WON A SHEEP ALSO TESTIFIED
KNOWING THAT SHE HAD THIS
CONTEXT.
THE SECOND TO SHE DIDN’T REVIEW
HER DOCUMENTS BEFORE SHE
TESTIFIED AND IT WAS A
PROCEEDING WHERE WE WERE
REMOVING THE PRESIDENT OF
UNITED STATES POSSIBLY.
NOT A GOOD SITUATION FOR THE
HERO OF THE HEARINGS.
>> Laura: NOW, HERE’S WHAT SHE
TOLD CONGRESS ABOUT THE OPTICS
OF HUNTER BIDEN’S JOB AT
BURISMA.
>> WAS THAT EVER, YOU KNOW, A
CONCERN, OR AT LEAST THE
PERCEPTION OF THAT CONCERN
ADDRESSED?
>> AS I SAID, I ARRIVED IN
AUGUST OF 2016.
SEVERAL MONTHS BEFORE THE
ELECTION AND SEVERAL MONTHS
BEFORE PRESIDENT TRUMP TOOK
OFFICE.
AND IT WAS NOT A FOCUS OF WHAT I
WAS DOING IN THAT SIX MONTH
PERIOD.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN, THESE
NEW DOCUMENTS SO THAT SHE SENT
150 PAGES WORTH OF EMAILS ABOUT
BURISMA.
>> SHE WAS FULL OF IT.
AND THIS IS A WOMAN WHO WAS
HIGHLY REGARDED AS AN
INTELLIGENT WOMAN.
SHE’S A PRINCETON-EDUCATED --
SHE SOMEONE WHO I DON’T BELIEVE
ACTUALLY DIDN’T RECALL, DIDN’T
REMEMBER, WHEN I WAS PRESSING
HER FOR ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
BEYOND THE PRESS REPORTS, WHAT
ELSE DID SHE KNOW ABOUT BURISMA?
AND ALL WE COULD GET BACK IS I
DON’T RECALL, I JUST DON’T BUY
THAT.
I THINK WE ARE ESSENTIALLY
SEEING IS A WHITEWASHING ATTEMPT
FROM THAT MOMENT SHE ARRIVED IN
AUGUST OF 201621 VICE PRESIDENT
BIDEN GOES TO UKRAINE IN JANUARY
OF 2017.
AS JOHN SOLOMON, CITIZENS UNITED
PRODUCED ALL OF THESE DIFFERENT
DOCUMENTS BETWEEN EMAILS,
MEETINGS, DISCUSSIONS, THERE’S
JUST NO WAY THAT SHE SHOWED UP
AT THAT IMPEACHMENT DEPOSITION
UNDER OATH ACTUALLY NOT
REMEMBERING ANY OF THIS.
>> Laura: JOHN, WASN’T THIS
IMPORTANT THAN THAT THE ELITES
IN THE MEDIA, MSNBC, THE FOLKS
AT ABC AND CNN, I MEAN, THEY
LIONIZED MARIE YOVANOVITCH.
SHE SHOULD HAVE BEEN UP ON
RUSHMORE AT THE END OF WHAT THEY
WERE SAYING.
IT WAS LIKE COLONEL VINDMAN,
LIEUTENANT COLONEL BENJAMIN AND
MARIA BONAVENTURE AND ALL THE
OTHER CAST AND CHARACTERS WHO
WERE CLEARLY VERY DISPLEASED
WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP AT THE
BOTTOM OF ALL OF THIS.
>> LISTEN, RIGHT NOW THEY’RE
BUILDING IN AMOUNT, MOUNT
SCHIFF, THERE’S GOING TO BE LIKE
CHRISTOPHER STEELE AND MARIE
YOVANOVITCH ON THE MOUNTAIN.
WHAT WE HAVE OUR GROUP OF
WITNESSES WHO GAVE US A FALSE
NARRATIVE AND IT TAKES MONTHS
AFTER ADAM SCHIFF PRESENTS HIS
ADDITIVES FOR WE AND THE METER
TO GET THE TRUTH TO DIG IT OUT.
EVERYTHING ABOUT THE SCHIFF SHOW
IS FALLING APART, WHETHER IT’S
RUSSIA OR UKRAINE.
I EXPECT A LOT OF BIG
REVELATIONS COMING UP IN UKRAINE
IN THE NEXT FEW WEEKS.
SENATOR RON JOHNSON TONIGHT
ANNOUNCED IT’S GOING TO ISSUE A
SUBPOENA TO THE VERY GROUP THAT
MET WITH HER TO TALK ABOUT
BURISMA IN DECEMBER OF 2016.
THAT’S A MAJOR NEW DEVELOPMENT.
>> Laura: IT’S HARD SOMETIMES
FOR REGULAR FOLKS OUT THERE,
CONGRESSMAN, TO KEEP THIS
VENN DIAGRAM OF, YOU KNOW, LIES,
DECEPTION, AND UNFAIR
PERSECUTION OF PEOPLE THAT HAS
TAKEN PLACE OVER THE LAST REALLY
FOUR OR FIVE YEARS, WE ARE NOW
BEGINNING TO SEE IT.
WE ARE NOW BEGINNING TO SEE IT.
>> YEAH, AMERICANS ARE SEEING
THE DOUBLE STANDARD.
THEY KNOW THAT IF MARIE
YOVANOVITCH WAS THERE TO REMOVE
PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA FROM
OFFICE, THAT YOU WOULD HAVE MANY
OF THESE SAME MAINSTREAM MEDIA
OUTLETS CALLING FOR THERE TO BE
A PERJURY INVESTIGATION INTO
HER, BUT INSTEAD THEY WILL
FACT-CHECK ALL OF THIS AND CLAIM
THAT NOTHING THAT SHE SAID WAS
DISHONEST, PROTECTING CLAPPER
AND WE ARE SEEING WITH POWER AND
OTHERS OTHERS AND SCHIFF WAS
MENTIONED -- EXACTLY.
>> Laura: WE WOULD HAVE